hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7 now
we're on the not a hero DLC and we've
got to go into the night vision place
which means this might be a bit spooky
so put on your spoofing pants yeah those
look like traps these are probably traps
- tik-tok mix mock blam - a MIDI ok I'm
gonna actually try to do this right
there we go oh wait I can't go there you
wait how many do I have now four is that
a good number I guess alright whatever
I'll wait till I get one more and then
see what I can do with that one
those are a lot of pressure plates on
the ground there
Lukas you planning something to do with
my pressure
I don't mind you planning for such
things
ooh that's right the lockpick I don't
know if there was a point of that but I
got it ramrods finally god I can't
believe I wasted two of those bad boys I
didn't know they were so rare whatever
not my fault oh hey how's it going there
buddy I'm just gonna fly right under
there wouldn't it be hilarious if we
pulled the prank and just spooked me by
setting off my my wrist bomb tripwire
okay I know I was about to I was about
to stand up and punch the red button I
would have ended Goodley okay but that's
why I would have dyed it because I
needed the night-vision huh would this
loose I don't trust that don't trust
that at all but I'm gonna [ __ ] yeah
oh what a kick stop stop don't know yeah
that's right crazies headless ones and
armless I don't like it yeah it's a ski
we know how could it be so how could
they have locked it
oh no I'm soo sad now okay I didn't feel
like it had enough momentum
to be able to break through all those
logs from that distance but okay Chris's
kick is just more powerful than I ever
could have imagined
oh yeah don't like that no I don't like
that at all oh all right well it's a
puzzle ain't it well let's push these
back here so I got no means of escape oh
did I mention I'm Chris Redfield and I'm
a badass was it son
something's tinkle tang : and I'm not
sure what okay well you need to go
through vatten hey come on now no yeah
it's right you I don't like the way Rhys
fact I don't like much anything that
rises well it's full of balloons Wow
okay all right that was fun
that's a fun one well oh that was a fun
one I like that one good one let me try
this one I'm gonna do anything I did
nothing all right
well happy that happened what's over
here now
anybody got a coin and I better get the
door that's lock from the other line and
if I got more balloons okay whatever you
say
yeah oh that's the clown door but I
can't get to the clown boy yet
ooh the clown for the clown door do you
have a clown key oh I bet you have tons
of clown keys crammed in your doors o
like a clown car
but a clown doors Oh instead clown
just with clown keys how many clowns you
got crammed into you am I going crazy
for saying clowns so much Oh antique
coin didn't even see that one
yeah antique clowns in there alright
well I don't trust you oh no no I hate
that knob yeah I don't like you and I
definitely don't like all the nails you
got there Wow whoa hey come on now no no
stop being dick all right well I got the
clown key yeah that's nice so now I can
revisit all the boo how about no and
these guys are tough when you don't hit
him in the face I forgot about that
quality oh hey oh hey wait wait wait
wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa whoa okay all right here we go hey
wait wait what oh no you're dead okay
well that sucks for you and I don't care
okay all right
excuse the shotgun for a bit I guess so
I can't use this to unlock the door
directly I bet but Oh would it consume
it I bet I bet I bet I don't know what's
telling me yes but I bet that it's
better to take this key back to the
center and use it there to unlock all
the doors if that is how this works
which it may not
[Music]
and then maybe that's gonna unlock all
of them whereas if I did that that I was
just there maybe it only would have done
win of him maybe I think again maybe not
maybe I'm crazy but I'm gonna go back
any whoa oh I can't never mind I'm not
gonna do that thing I my theory is
goodbye my execution is [ __ ] so I'm
gonna go over here and use it on this
door ah I see okay ah it was whoa all
right who wants some huh
want some hello Oh limbo
ah lobotomy wait I just got that heavy
feeling of traps you know I don't like a
heavy feeling of traps I mean obviously
there's traps but I think there's might
be other traps okay real sneaky
channeling my inner Tom Cruise in
Mission Impossible okay that was good
Mission Possible what well that guy's
dead why I didn't even notice that guy
that guy is so dead hmm okay all right
well one false move in this guy is dunzo
probably yeah he are you breathing no a
little bit maybe yeah he's moving okay
all right he's still alive but not for
long
definitely not for long okay okay good
job standing up before you get down you
idiot okay okay okay all right
[Music]
like a butterfly what is this
shotgun ammo per bag anything up on the
uppers uppers no okay all right well
here I come body on this precarious
playing
how you doing there you were one of our
best right
ow
what the hell oh okay well alright then
I didn't know that okay
saving your fellow soldier while the
traps are still active is dangerous well
how did I know it's not like you gave me
much of screw you you know screw you hey
yo
oh I gotta go all the way from the
beginning no I'm coming I'm coming Chris
Redfield like a lumbering behemoth in
the night I'm a lumber my way over here
to you alright I'm not gonna try to be
careful how was I supposed to know that
he'd have a remote control over it huh
freakin douche I'll get you in a second
I guess I didn't know I was supposed to
do this god it's not like there's rules
here so shut up [ __ ] all right what
about this Oh poo ski couch uncle's ah
that's the good stuff okay all right
well did that was there a way to
deactivate the traps for the other guys
can I just leave look just leave don't
leave your comrade oh sure okay all
right yeah okay hey hey you still with
us
yeah it's you thanks I was beginning to
think we've been left behind yeah ain't
gonna work out so well for you I imagine
okay
why are you groaning so much what's
wrong with your butt why are you
grabbing it like that okay you got some
hip displacement alright sure whatever
you say oh yeah I'm sure you're gonna
get out of this alive
three men Lucas three of my men dead
because of you
this ends and it ends now
okay
we got a situation here okay all right
well this is bad well jeez at least he
gave me a ten minute timer this my
friends didn't get the same luxury whoa
oh yeah wait hang on you go you go you
go ahead I got time oh no what happened
- Wham
all right I'm going I'm going I'm going
all right I'm going golly gee all right
hey don't step on the whoa don't stay
hey don't step on the thing oh he's
stepping on the thing he's not stepping
on the thing all right well he laying on
the thing well that's got to count for
something
all right we got through there all right
yeah okay okay whatever you say let me
shave so that I don't die a horrible
death from explosion disease you have to
deactivate oh come on I don't have to
deactivate the bomb first what are you
what are you a big baby come on I can do
both I can multitask come on please hmm
how about no oh shoot my face hey you no
no no okay all right see you see you
guys my guys dead all right well I'm a
run along I'm screwed Lee do over here
go up this place whatever have you see
buddies kind of got a bomb next to me
why would he give a why would you give
me a timer knob them that doesn't make
any sense they had a timer already and
they were out of time I'm not sure why
does it why does it match up with my own
heads-up display that man that makes
even less sense is it over here no still
over here
I'm gone why don't I have a map on this
thing oh hey wait wait wait wait wait
wait buddy get makes me laugh every time
I laugh every time
oh wait another one okay that's no good
all right hang on hang on hang on all
right wait is there a crawler skittering
after me oh yeah there are but I need to
switch to the other cuz I need a
precision oh no he's dead
nevermind no precision oh where am I
going
oh the clown door I've got a clown key
oh okay I get it
I forgot that I could just unlocking I
got you
cloud or clown key let's go clown town
grenades that I haven't been using oh I
do not have the bullets for you scram
I could have just run for it I guess
hello anybody here bullets okay alright
where did this go this is where I wanted
to be the queer nitrogen hello
well I got an antique coin I guess
that's the best of both worlds hello
hello how am I going oh the other way
the way oh that's big and bright how did
I miss that okay alright well least I
found the secret area hey yeah oh sweet
I got super juice gum oh nine of them
yes
how am I gonna need them okay so uh
what's stopping me from ten rum you
think it's gonna be zombies I think
there's gonna be ramrod zombies just
scouting around I'm sure I have time
okay I I met every real pissed if like
oh I don't want to eat [ __ ] and die oh
they're outhouses Oh
I bought it Oh very lovely
oh do I punch him yeah oh yeah sure ok
let's go with that one yeah that's
that's great I love his split head brain
Oh boom oh he just belly smacked me
yeah douche thanks for waiting for me to
get back up you freakin douche you're
not gonna let you oh god I got a right
heel run run run ok
alright come on come on come on come on
hey I don't know if a grenade will work
on him
I want to punch you again well I'm out
of those so what do I do now
oh well alright then how about I just
shove this in your gob oh oh oh I'm
gonna punch I'm gonna punch
I'm gonna punch punch
[ __ ] dude take another why these for the
road ye all right there oh oh oh did I
get them wait wait did he go down wait
I'm a bunch of hot husky rule threes
baby you dad you done you down for oh
you don't look done oh wait there's
something over there yeah wait yeah
please wait wait oh here we go ring
around the rosy pocket full of posy this
is a waste of ammo but I hope it's a ray
Oh gross oh that's not good hang on wait
oh geez oh jesus oh Jesus firebomb I'm a
firebomb you guys ooh
fireball fireball firebomb Oh like I'm
on top but even better apparently oh god
I hate that well that's that's no good
yeah
hate that weren't you just letting on
forward oh yeah yeah yeah you let me
give that punch b roll force or
something oh wow ramrod all right okay
yeah I'll just go through this outhouse
excuse me knock knock anybody home let's
see yeah okay
hey convenient convenient
all right just dip my hand in there
whole hand just dip it in yes sir okay
yeah throw it dumbass [ __ ] Oh God it's
so dangerous fine okay it's just you and
me and apparently I'm supposed to take
him alive or something
the shield machine you say you mean like
the drill in the mine
the shield machine god I did it again
god I don't know why even that time I
wasn't even trying to crouch alright
whatever there's another clown room in
the other area I kind of want to go find
but I don't know if it'll be worth it
but I kind of want to go find it it'd be
nice to get all those clowns I don't
know if it's like some super special
bonus or nothing but I'm gonna all right
what do we got anybody gonna mess with
me it's amazing how much havoc Lucas can
wreak like Ethan went through these
mines himself why didn't Luke his wasted
Sam on him
I mean who tried to kill him before but
his machinations didn't work and he had
enough time to move his clown buddy oh
well whatever
alright I'm gonna go to the other one
and I'm gonna check out the other clown
door before I go to this one just
because I can and I'm kind of like
wanting to be thorough about this hey
yeah let me through please thank you
okay
I think he was down here I think it was
just around the corner on the inside so
I don't think I have to go very far
about it the Condors a lot of what he
does doesn't make it always right right
here okay alright clown door clown clown
II what do you have for me baby
clowny hmm okay
well I guess I was worth it got
stabilizer out there I think that's like
one of those permanent upgrades isn't it
yeah Jimmy
sweet I think I got enough coins to do
everything else so why not
my reload speed increased that's super
useful right now probably maybe a little
bit probably I think a lot maybe I'm not
Harvison sure about that but yeah I'm
gonna go with ya I want to go with a
whole lot of yeah okay all right anyway
where is it again Oh who's up here yeah
that's right
okay I got it nobody worry about
anything all right so once I get these
I'm gonna activate the clown there
because apparently he gave away for us
to get him I don't know why
steroids increased max health
indefinitely wait oh wait I don't have
enough for both stabilizer reload speed
increases indefinitely
I'd rather every load speed than the
other one maybe I'll get more later
okok I'd do it one at time oh man why is
his family loved their ancient coins so
much alright I guess that was worth it
if it was worth five so got that ooh
wait how do I get there were stewards
and that in there hmm nice okay alright
I'll take both yeah give me that
steroids yeah this is our Chris this is
our Chris got in trouble
this is constantly jamming steroids and
stabilizers in his arms it's got the
steadiest Roy deist hand
yeah that's a drill not a shield that's
drill drill baby drill I guess but
that's a drill okay all right glad I did
that
okay all right stop now very scary big
machine so Wow come on now is not the
time for that really Oh what no you're
stupid only five save slots what am I
gonna do with five save slots nothing
that's what I'm gonna do all right let's
go
I don't care what he my diction is doing
out here shouldn't even be in friends
hey how's it going here get ramrod those
things this that flips flap okay well I
seem to be gearing me up for a battle of
some sorts I'm gonna keep this with the
ramrod ammo and I keep this with the
knot ramrod ammo dark in here no night
vision
okay
no no no how do you what are you
controlling these things doing that
how are you doing that Lukas are you
sending them out all at once where's
that it won't don't stop believin hold
on to the feeling wait you're pouring
out of the ceiling
oh is why I kept you and you alright so
far so goo how are you sending these
guys out Lukas I don't understand how
you have any sort of control over any of
this
it's a lot of goop writing down on my
face and I don't like it dude you don't
even know who I am
whoa what the hell yeah your head out
here whoa well that ain't good I don't
like the way that looks oh this is easy
I think you're gonna give me a challenge
here hold on
Waldo your doors oh come on oh god you
son of a [ __ ] no oh you got him it's
just a body shot for them so it's
nothing even too bad I don't even need
to aim with this thing
you're slowing down Christopher not
really man uh probably a lot oh don't do
that don't do that hey take your grenade
oh wow
hey I realize I didn't even throw the
grenade whoo oh well this is bad
oh come on this is gross this is
disgusting all right take one of these
now oh he's doing the thing he's doing
the thing he's gonna blow oh well
because he didn't blow all right well
still gonna do a lot of this
oh come on oh titty sprinkles come on
all right now you're dead okay good
finally
that's the sound of him dying or oh we
didn't die okay all right well Oh what
the hell it happened there I don't know
what was that oh wow what what all right
well that was easy
take one of these this is a victory who
found it barely oh no no I didn't yeah I
agree with that sentiment sure yeah okay
yeah well that's how I'm gonna get away
we're watching so you don't know so
strong oh no come on now come on just
let me sweet talk just great here come
on
you know I'm markiplier by the way did
you know that I bet you didn't know that
okay down I go we 500 that's not good
well I'd probably worried about this if
I didn't have an absolute certainty that
I was gonna get away from it we oh hey
fire I don't really need night vision
down here it's very Bernie very bright
okay I guess I do all right sure
let's go with that huh where else are
you gonna send me up that way no I'm
emotionally traumatized this might be
our chance do you send it to me okay
well I didn't find another I didn't find
any other lockpicks where the hell am I
I just went out of the mines and into
some facility I thought I was at the
Baker farm why am i over here how do I
get over here also where is here the
only thing that was nearby would have
been the boat and it's definitely not
the boat whoa
hey buddy okay
don't mind me oh yeah I got the bullets
for them but I don't want to doing a
disturbing okay it's weird
whoo skew II okay nice clown thing okay
oh this is his lab where he was doing
tests okay I get it okay well I'll just
have to take care of him Oh clean room
no need oh hey buddy whoa whoa
oh wait what wait what wait what wait
what how are you under that bed that
doesn't make any sense
how are you under that bed I feel like I
would have seen you what did I just get
did I get a long picker mad thing ooh
creepy okay okay this was for Evelyn I
guess was everyone down here oh look at
that
look at that what a happy family yes
sure okay
I live here but I just kid I never know
what I get before I get him I guess I
got anti those things bullets yeah okay
all right I don't know whose blood that
is but all right well I guess I'm out of
here oh yeah it's probably some story to
be gleaned from that but I'm not on
represent sure what they're trying to
say okay got those all right well moving
on yeah anyway actually I am actually
all I know I'm probably close to the end
of this but you know what I'm gonna
carry on y'all carry on you gotta get up
yeah yeah yeah you were alright see you
haven't been able to punch anybody I'm
sick of this guy Lucas they just give
him my job as lead researcher who do
they think I am why do I a Stanford
graduate with a master's in microbiology
have to work under this lunatic all he
does is mess around with the test
subjects making them all fight each
other and doing unnecessary autopsies
he's sick he knows nothing about the
e-series muta my sets potential I'm
gonna report his behavior of the next HQ
meeting all right well I wonder how that
worked out for you buddy owner who's
blood this is now so there were other
people working in this facility that was
near the Baker's so like this whole
facility was set up here just for the
Baker's benefit is that what I'm
supposed to believe here I'm gonna go to
the other end mo because I want to use
the pistol a little bit no power of
course there's no Lucas can I shoot you
in the back of the hood body hey Lucas
how do you not notice me Lucas Ludi
Lucas Lucas all right actually I'm all
out sound for this episode so I'm gonna
end this one here thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know anything
down the comments below
and as always I'll see you in this video
[Music]